deux concurrentes à partenaires alors
que kamala harris avait débuté les
primaires démocrates en tant que rivale
de joe biden elle est désormais aux
côtés du candidat pour affronter donald
trump non moins de trois mois
cette nouvelle alliance pourrait
permettre pour la première fois aux
états unis à une femme de devenir vice
président pour sa première apparition
publique le nouveau tandem s'est montré
déterminé au cours des dernières
semaines j'ai eu l'incroyable privilège
de rencontrer et de passer pas mal de
temps avec plusieurs femmes dirigeantes
talentueuse toutes qualifiées pour être
présidente et ce matin dans tout le pays
des petites filles se sont réveillés en
particulier des petites filles noires et
métisses qui se sentent si souvent
négligée sous-estimé dans leur
communauté
mais aujourd'hui peut-être qu'elles se
voient pour la première fois d'une
nouvelle manière comme les toffes du
président et des vice-présidents
première femme de couleur choisie à
cette fonction pour représenter l'un des
deux grands partis américains
kamala harris s'inscrit dans le contexte
politique actuel marqué par un mouvement
de protestation historique contre le
racisme
un atout majeur pour joe biden
s'appuyant sur les difficultés
économiques des états unis et sur la
crise sanitaire mondiale la sénatrice de
californie n'hésite pas à tacler le
président donald trump
tout ce qui nous importe notre économie
notre santé nos enfants le type de pays
dans lequel nous vivons tout est en jeu
nous sommes en train de surmonter la
pire crise de santé publique du siècle
c'est ce qui arrive quand on élit un
type qui n'est tout simplement pas à la
hauteur
le choix de kamala harris s'avère
surprenant pour donald trump
ce dernier a qualifié de médiocre les
performances de la sénatrice de
californie aux primaires a fait que je
pense qu'elle va être un grand échec
j'attends avec impatience le débat entre
elles et mike pence parce que je pense
qu'il fera encore mieux compte
réel que contre le sénateur kane qui
avait été un échec total
nommé kamala harris comme colistière
permet en tout cas de rajeunir la
campagne de joe biden si le candidat
démocrate l'emportent en novembre
prochain
il deviendrait à 77 ans le plus vieux
président américain à prendre ses
fonctions